the new series of babylon 5 has been
pushed back to 2023
it's not going to be happening this year
as we hoped
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
um
so it's been announced today and
confirmed by jms himself on his patreon
account that babylon 5 will not be
happening this year the pilot is not
being given the go-ahead as we hoped
now normally this would be a death nail
in the series it would basically mean it
ain't happening but strazinsky has
actually said that he got a personal
phone call from the president of the cw
bonk pedowicz told him in that phone
call that the show will be going ahead
that he loves the script for the pilot
but
they just can't do it right now he's
pushing it back to 2023 after the sale
of the cw goes through and the dust is
settled in pedo it's his own words
so what does this actually mean well the
cw is still moving ahead with other
projects
gotham knights got the go-ahead to have
a pilot as did prequels to walker texas
ranger called walker independence and a
prequel to the supernatural the
winchesters
these projects have been given a
go-ahead but
if i'm honest
they're not going to require the
investment that the babylon 5 series
would have done
babylon 5 is going to be a relatively
expensive project and to be honest once
you go ahead with the pilot that is a
significant investment
you really have to be sure that if
you're going with a pilot that you are
going to go on to create the series and
that you have the investment to do so
in this case i think
the project was just maybe a little bit
too big for the current situation with
the cw sale and they decided just to put
it back 12 months
but i actually do think this is still
going ahead i don't think jms would have
released a statement he did and i'm
absolutely certain the cw president mr
pedowitz wouldn't have made the phone
call he had done and given jms
permission to actually make that public
unless they were pretty confident they
were still going to go ahead with the
project so let's see what happens but
what we can say for absolute certain is
we're not going to be getting babylon 5
on our screens this year and i've got to
say
i'm a little disappointed
with everything else that's going on in
2022
this might have been something to look
forward to but hey we're just going to
have to hope that it gives us the joy we
deserve in 2023 instead
so please guys get in the comments tell
me what you think about this sad news
that we're going to have to wait another
year for babylon 5 and tell me what you
think actually about this project is
this something you want to see this hard
reboot that's going to be completely
different in lots of ways to the
original is this something you want to
see
and if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification you can join the channel
become a sidetracker and support us and
also you can join us on facebook
there'll be a link in the description
thanks very much guys and as always stay
safe